it is realistic for four people it three
possibly four it's not realistic for one
person in the land of the the overall
title of personal assistant encompasses
a lot of things but and the hybrid
they're referred to as hybrid jobs that
the personal assistance / household
manager that's half that job description
that was in there was fine you know all
the things about dry cleaning and plants
and managing the house in managing his
personal comings and goings travel and
even traveling with him however the
tasks of the personal branding requires
a marketing person and the handling the
children and the pets that may require
and bringing on a nanny certainly a
seasoned professional assistant could
supervise all of those people and be a
chief of staff type there's no question
about that but even that it 50 to 60,000
pounds is really underpaid in this
business you get what you pay for and
and here's the thing i'm sure germain
wants all of these tasks done to in a
very excellent way you know in a very
professional way and therefore you get
what you pay for so the the job
description of the PA hm the household
manager definitely would command 85,000
pounds not 50 to 60 it's not being
priced accordingly I think what's making
a lot of people laugh is the in Congress
nature of the task sees demanding you
know some of these very price highly
sophisticated jobs but also stocking the
fridge watering the plants buying
birthday presents for his mother on
Mother's Day presents what's what's he
going to be left with to do yeah well
you know that's very busy people
celebrities that that's pretty much the
norm that's fine I mean the Givens are
that there are only 24 hours in a day
even Germain only gets 24 hours in a day
but the thing is that a personal
assistant is going to be working five
days a week maybe six days a week it
will be really important to get this job
description in writing I mean I read it
and I found myself thinking who create
this and has he ever had an assistant
before my thought was he needs some
guidance here that it that you know you
can't blame them for trying for wanting
all of that but but to do all of those
tasks well will not be found in one
person it will be found in multiple
people yeah have you come across any
kind of unreasonable demands like that
in your in your career oh my gosh well I
trained high-level executive and
personal assistants all around the world
I worked for Olympia Dukakis for 25
years and it wouldn't have lasted for 25
years had she been unreasonable and
irrational you know everybody always
points to devil wears prada thinking and
and her the the most seasoned
professional assistance can handle very
demanding employers what's really not
possible or the the unreasonable and the
irrational you know a colleague of mine
was asked to delay a plane from taking
off and actually she was successful if
that's totally against the rules or
another one was called in the middle of
the night because her celebrity employer
had on a whim decided to ask her to find
this very rare puppy because he wanted
to give it as a present to his wife and
he needed to get on it right then I
believe that it's wearing yeah and body
presumably and in light of some of the
stories you're telling there they're
buying silence aren't there you if
you're paying a lot of money one thing
you're paying for is confidentiality
that this person doesn't subsequently
start washing your dirty laundry in
public for a fee from a newspaper
magazine yes indeed confidentiality is
paramount absolutely discretion and the
word goes around certainly that you know
the world is hungry for stories about
the rich and famous people so you've got
to know that assistance they know a lot
but they're paid to not share and they
do sign confidentiality agreements and
it would be very important to honor that
confidentiality because it doesn't get
any more personal than being in
someone's home
having access to to knowing pretty much
everything I mean people knew that to
get to me was almost better than getting
to Olympia because I knew her schedule
and I could make things happen Olympia
would often say why are you asking me
talk to Bonnie and that's what most
people will do with their personal
assistance so it's really important to
pay them what they're worth and to be
realistic and reasonable about what can
be expected I mean Jermaine needs to
rest and and have a day off and the job
description has written is not possible
for one person and it's unreasonable